[Musique]
le train voyageur numéro 5327 en
provenance de moscou et à destination de
st petersbourg va partir
le train de marchandises numéro 5309 en
provenance de tumen et à destination de
la cam chat pea est parti
[Musique]
le train militaire numéro 5204 à
destination de la base navale part de la
gare de ce chiffre
[Musique]
je voyais ces destinations pont s
en général quand les gens parlent d'un
projet comme celui-ci il se pose trois
questions fondamentales
combien cela va-t-il coûter combien de
temps cela va-t-il prendre pour
l'assemblée et qu'en sera-t-il renta
pour moi la réponse à ces trois
questions a toujours été la même une
réponse très ferme est tout à fait
convaincante n'a je ne sais pas de toute
évidence il était difficile de se lancer
dans un partenariat avec moi équipe face
à une telle situation
c'est pourquoi je suis venu à la
conclusion que si je voulais faire
quelque chose je devais compter sur mes
propres capacités
il y avait à saint pétersbourg une usine
spécialisée dans la fabrication de
produits à base d'amiante dans les
années 1990 cuisine a été privatisée et
j'en suis devenu l'un des propriétaires
bonjour je gagner assez d'argent pour me
permettre de voyager j'avais beaucoup de
temps pour me détendre pendant ses
voyages mais je voulais vraiment
utiliser cette énergie à bon escient et
narguer au début je voulais créer un
modèle de saint-péterbourg de nuit mais
l'appétit vient en mangeant
je me suis aperçu que saint pétersbourg
ne serait pas suffisant ce serait trop
local trop petit il me semblait que je
pouvais essayer de créer quelque chose
de plus grand que la peu je suis arrivé
à l'idée de créer une maquette à grande
échelle de la russie au brésil
que non
tout
l'exceptionnelle pour nos routes se
caser tous et sur tout autre attaque
notre vous parler à n'importe qui dans
la rue on vous dira qu il y 100 m² si
gigantesque pas trop triste la plupart
des appartements faisant entre 30 et 40
mètres carrés cela équivaut à 20
appartements
c'est beaucoup quand d'art monacelli
prostate ce taux est au premier chef
mais quand nous avons commencé à
assembler les premières installations
j'ai été choqué de ne pas avoir assez
d'espacé pour y faire entrer le pays où
même une ville ou un quartier
cela m'a effrayée samaté routes et aux
propos de temps ça m'a mis quasiment
chaos comme un boxeur qui reçoit un coup
inattendu après photo da et maintenant
je peux dire avec certitude que 800 m²
sont insignifiants sûreté même 8000 ne
suffirait pas m maxime tu te rappelles
ce qu'on voulait faire ici on voulait y
faire un village
aux caves comme au temps des coups de
petites zones agricoles desjardins
quelques remises des toilettes un
épouvantail vous voulez dire
deschamps séparé par une façade et une
clôture et la bourre non il y aurait une
clôture entre celle là entre ses maisons
donc oui une barrière entre voisins
malgré l'affection que les gens ont les
uns pour les autres ils construisent
toujours des barrières entre leurs
parcelles
il ya je voulais devenir médecin à aider
les gens mais quand j'avais huit ans mes
parents m'ont inscrite à l'école d'art
c'est là que tout a commencé
j'essaie vraiment beaucoup plus simple
dans la vraie vie vous allez dans un
champ vous semez mène au planton ici ce
tournesol depuis cinq mois et il y en a
plus de 20000
je suis venu ici le 9 octobre 2011 avec
mes amis driano à chenilles et puis en
entrant dans le musée j'ai immédiatement
été hypnotisé j'étais comme un zombie
j'ai été fasciné par la taille par la
quantité de travail
le fait que les petites voitures roulent
je n'arrivais pas à comprendre comment
ça fonctionne il y avait même des
accidents de voiture
j'étais très impressionné comment est il
possible de créer tout ça c'était une
toute petite équipe et j'avais envie de
les rejoindre
je cherche un emploi à ce moment là mes
amis m'ont demandé tu veux travailler
ici et j'ai dit oui
ils m'ont amené dans le bureau de sergei
m'ont fait ce soir devant lui et j'ai
dit je veux travailler ici à ce que
n'ont rien que tu le dises rabat
la russie est le plus grand pays du
monde
raymond en termes de superficie cela
signifie que si je voulais faire un
modèle à une échelle de un pour 87
j'aurai besoin d'une superficie égale à
celle d'un pays comme le royaume uni
à ce moment là il était extrêmement
difficile vraiment difficile de
comprendre ce que je devais faire
ensuite j'ai réalisé que pour compenser
cela je devais me débarrasser de
certaines choses
omettre certains détails j'ai dû
travailler au niveau macro ce qui
signifie que je devais aller jusqu'à au
maître des régions entières
mon travail est de 12 heures à 14 heures
par jour mais le modèle lui même était
en construction 24 heures sur 24 jours
et nuits non je vivais pratiquement ici
mais surtout j'ai pu constituer une
équipe très qualifiés ce qui est
extrêmement important il croyait tous au
projet et on en fait une partie de même
si une partie de leurs vignes
alexei écoute on va le mettre sur les
rails
il doit être placé de manière à ce que
les visiteurs puissent le voir quand je
suis arrivé ici la partie ouest du
projet n'était qu'un cadre recouvert de
contreplaqué vous savez une table plate
du côté oriental il commencé à
construire le paysage
j'ai été étonné par l'ampleur du projet
c'est la première chose ensuite j'ai
compris son potentiel important de
saint-louis d'ostende
j'ai commencé à travailler ici en tant
que modéliste donc tout en bas de
l'échelle
mais à paris j'ai été premier chef
j'ai besoin dans notre fils si on nous
compare aux vrais pays à la vraie russie
je suppose qu'on pourrait comparer mon
poste à celui de ministre des transports
préfet s'appuie
[Musique]
dans les montagnes de l'oural nous avons
un poste de contrôle il s'agit de
systèmes qui gèrent l'ensemble du modèle
il contrôle les chemins de fer il régule
la circulation des véhicules et le
système qui fait passer du jour à la
nuit et vice versa la locomotive 5332
est arrivé à l'as cannes chaque cas pour
être accrochés au punk rock
[Musique]
c'est vrai on peut lancer
afin d'avoir autant de types de trains
différents que possible traversant la
rue si nous utilisons des échangeurs
rotatif
sont tous contrôlés par ordinateur
chacun de ces échangeurs peut stocker
jusqu'à 30 trains lorsqu'un train arrive
un autre part pour le remplacer sténopé
[Musique]
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous avons discuté
d'une nouvelle scène dans un village à
proximité de la région nord j'ai déjà
commencé à travailler dessus
le travail sur n'importe quelle scène
commence par la construction d'un
paysage caractéristiques de cette scène
cela peut sembler facile à faire mais ce
ne l'est pas du tout
après que vous devez créer des montagnes
des collines beyter indifférent ce sont
par exemple
à ma droite nous avons une scène divers
sur laquelle j'ai travaillé une année
entière voilà ce que ça donne au final
on en connaît selon elle nous avons eu
beaucoup de problèmes à gérer nous ne
savions pas par exemple comment
fabriquer de la neige des crêtes de
glace ou des monticules de neige
nous avons dû coller de faux glaçons
signifie créer des transitions de
l'hiver le town positionner des
différentes couches positionner des
figurines jouant dans la neige des parcs
divers construire une piste enneigée
[Musique]
nous devons installer un sixième
aiguillages sur la route 26 pour nous
assurer que les autres parties de la
route fonctionne correctement d'accord
essayé de l'installer maintenant face de
nous des finitions les directions à
l'aide d'aiguillage afin de diversifier
le trafic sur la maquette
ils sont similaires aux aiguillages de
tramway que l'on voit pour les tramways
ordinaire à l'heure actuelle nous
installons précisément ce type
d'aiguillage afin de pouvoir changer les
directions des voitures
après l'obtention de mon diplôme
universitaire j'ai été muté dans un
institut de recherche scientifique dans
un laboratoire secret qui travaillait
pour le ministère de la défense
j'ai participé au développement d'un
système de communication pour la défense
militaires russes des communications
sécurisées disons ça comme ça
[Musique]
comme un druze et un peu voici les
minières quand mes amis m'ont invité à
travailler sur la maquette en tant qu
ingénieur électrique ordinaire et à
stains début je ne comprenais pas très
bien ce que j'allais faire
c'est le chant de la route 17 est faible
et said appuyer sur le bouton 25
mais ensuite sergueï morozov m'a donné
carte blanche elle m'a pris à part et
m'a dit vladimir fais ce que tu penses
être nécessaire cela m'a mis à l'aise
pas quoi
[Musique]
elles devront probablement changer le
relais tiens ça va maintenant mars la
partie supérieure de la maquette est
intéressante pour tout le monde elle est
pittoresque et excitant mais en tant que
technicien je suis plus intéressé par ce
qui se trouve sous la marque et je me
sens chez moi ici je connais tous les
sites et c'est sûr
[Musique]
pire il ya les amis avec qui j'ai
travaillé au laboratoire secret ils sont
encore ce que c'est ok à nice et à la
beauté
ni taiwo récemment proposé de les
rejoindre mais mon coeur appartient déjà
ce projet pays les maquettes tulliste y
at il quelque chose de plus merveilleux
que cette maquette est une vraie
merveille
ennahda est aussi chef parfois j'ai
envie je rêve de devenir minuscule stade
taquine vers 1 86e de ma taille et me
promener dans notre petite russie ici et
parler à fixer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais nous voulions créer un modèle
réaliste qui représenterait la vie
dépeindrait la vie telle qu'elle est en
extrême orient par exemple les
garde-côtes ont arraisonné un navire de
braconniers et arrêter son équipage
ici des tigres de sibérie sont en chasse
sur cette petite berges de sibérie des
prospecteurs cherche de l'or dans la
taïga des touristes sont tombés sur une
maman ours et ses oursons et se sont
fait une belle frayeur
c'est une scène assez vivante il ya
aussi un ermite solitaire qui vit dans
la taïga nas dans le nord les
scientifiques ont découvert les restes
d'un mammouth laineux piégé dans le
permafrost et pendant les temps de
voisines les fans des éleveurs de rennes
prépare le dîner
[Musique]
et les maisons des villes du nord repose
sur des piliers et non sur le sol tout
comme dans la réalité ni ma scène
préférée et c'est la préférée de tous
nos visiteurs
c'est probablement celles associées pour
le petit garçon a volé le haut de
maillot de bain d'une femme et court sur
le ponton alors qu elle le poursuit
[Musique]
je parle le terrain pour un faire un
champ des potagers et une forêt je le
parle j plantes l'herbe
j'ajoute différentes pierres et sable
complètement au hasard 100 entre
particuliers
pour l'instant le plus dur c'est de
devoir faire des pauses ans
[Musique]
d'un mois sur la maquette du lot jour
dure 15 millions tandis que la nuit dure
deux minutes elle tombe progressivement
d'est en ouest
[Musique]
dès que vous avez par la scène est
appliqué de la colle tout d'un coup il
fait sombre
clive la colle sèche et vous devez tout
recommencer
[Musique]
lure a ici une forêt dense zones
arborées qui séparera le village de la
voie ferrée je voudrais concevoir une
scène près du village
représentant le début de l'automne avec
des personnages qui coupent l'herbe et
ramasse le foin
c'est une image il y dédier une vision
artistique mais pas d'un seul artiste
noms de plusieurs c'est notre vision
mais beaucoup de gens ne comprennent pas
ça
[Musique]
il ya toujours des gens pour vous
critiquer pour être honnête pour nous
sommes toujours respectueux compréhensif
ouvert à toute critique par exemple dans
notre extrême orient il y a une base
aérienne militaire où des hélicoptères
de combat sont au sol à l'héliport un
jour un homme est venu nous voir
je comprends maintenant qu'il devait
avoir des liens avec le domaine de
l'aviation et nous a dit vous avez un
appareil avec le numéro 13 il n'y a pas
de 13 dans l'aviation
nous l'avons remercié et avons corrigé
l'erreur le jour même
hadzic néanmoins c'est très souvent
désagréable est vraiment dommage que des
gens commencent à nous critiquer sans
avoir examiné le modèle attentivement
disent des choses comme vous avez des
sous marins donc il devrait y avoir un
cochon rôti
mais le fait est que nous avons un
cuisinier qui tient un cochon rôti pour
célébrer le retour du sous marin
nous savions qu'ils ont cette tradition
dans la marine et nous l'avons mis en
scène orienté pédales
[Musique]
il est également difficile d'imaginer la
russie sans sa célèbre architecture en
bois
c'est pourquoi nous avons des pièces
représentant des bâtiments unique qui
ont été construits sans le moindre flou
pour être tout à fait honnête j'ai
depuis longtemps arrêté de compter le
nombre de personnes qui vivent
actuellement dans notre maquette de la
russie mais je sais avec certitude que
sa population peut être mesurée en
centaines de milliers et si la police
est en train d'arrêter les gens là bas
ils ont mis tout le monde contre le mur
nous
[Musique]
moi le petit garçon au pull bleu près du
zoo on ne touche pas au modèle s'il te
plaît
[Musique]
après la visite d'un groupe les pales du
rotor d'un hélicoptère était plié il a
fallu beaucoup de travail pour les
restaurer de temps en temps de petites
figurines ou certaines parties de leur
corps disparaissent une tête par ci une
jambe par là nous avons une scène où les
habitants manifestent fauconnier ils ne
manifestent pas contre un système
politique particulier mais contre le
traitement parfois terribles leur impose
des visiteurs qui les vendent à lies and
i ils tiennent des pancartes exigeant
que les gens les respectent qui ne les
touche pas et ne les casse parade
la staatliche la différence entre notre
maquette et les maquettes européenne et
que la nôtre n'est pas une maquette
ferroviaire c'est une maquette c'est
dans une autre pays et j'allais vers le
chemin de fer n'est pas réellement
l'élément clé ici il ne fait que donner
vie à l'ensemble du mercato si vous
voyagez à travers la vraie russie en
train cela vous prendra presque une
semaine on a ce staff sur la maquette le
train de saint pétersbourg à vladivostok
roule pendant 15 20 minutes à une
vitesse moyenne de 20 cm par seconde
soit 7 cm
soit il y à un accident sur la route 6
un train a déraillé
un problème avec l'aiguillage secourisme
ici tout est comme dans la vraie vie
et comme dans la vraie vie nous avons
des accidents arrivé à cause de
poussière sur les rails de la saleté un
peu de poussière ou un cheveu tout cela
peut provoquer un accident vérifier si
tout va bien on peut démarrer
la poussière est une préoccupation
depuis le tout début de ce projet nous
avons installé un équipement spécial et
une quantité incroyable de tapis
absorbant la poussière instinct à 7
voire en plus de cela nous avons deux
moyen de nettoyer l'intérieur du hall
d'abord le hall d'exposition est soumis
à une pression supérieure à celle de
l'extérieur afin d'expulser la poussière
his body schnyder bling le deuxième
moyen consiste tout simplement à souvent
laver les sols pour s'assurer que la
salle est parfaitement propre
je suis souvent obligés de marcher sur
la surface des modèles et sur l'eau pour
finir certaines choses des gens me
voient et plaisante à regarder un géant
c'est gulliver c'est dieu le maître de
la russie
[Musique]
yoshi faso je voulais vraiment
représenté l'époque d'avant la
révolution et la victoire lors de la
seconde guerre mondiale douanières et
j'ai presque immédiatement compris
comment procéder nous avons créé un
immense studio de cinéma où on tourne
des films et nous avons tout reconstruit
dans ce 40 m'assister nous avons une
scène de l'arrivée du train royal
voyez c'est dur à l'aîné
ap en face une locomotive et tire une
plateforme chargé de matériel de
tournage
il ya aussi des grands décors qui montre
le tournage d'un film sur la seconde
guerre mondiale tard l'équipe des chars
de l'artillerie des soldats étrangers
des explosions tout y exposer car la
précision des détails est tel que
fondamentalement vous ne pouvez pas voir
l'intégralité de ses scènes sans
utiliser des jumelles
en parallèle il y à des cinéastes qui
tourne un film de science fiction à
proximité pour montrer que beaucoup de
films contemporains sont tournés en
russie comment cela se fait-il que
l'ovni ne tombe pas regarde qui ne
repose sur rien je ne sais pas
[Musique]
hier je place des maisons jeudi visent
des parcelles et je mets des voitures à
leur place
certains sont déjà arrivés larves
hatcher et d'autres sont encore en route
les maisons sont très belle volée
sculpté et leurs habitants sont
extraordinaires
[Musique]
on
il me semble que dans l'ensemble tout va
bien nishio à ekaterina la cabine est là
bas elle est abandonnée celle là c'est
ça dans ce cas il faut appliquer un peu
de peinture de couleur rouille
sinon elle semble trop brillants
entrepreneurs l'idée là c'est un peu
plus coloré ici un peu plus simple la
bat ekaterina je pense que tu as fait un
excellent travail comme d'habitude
son travail est terminé
[Musique]
à
je pense à tous les défis auxquels nous
avons été confrontés à des difficultés
les complexités normal
on avait l'impression qu'on pouvait rien
faire locaux des eaux comment mais un
merveilleux proverbe russe me vient à
l'esprit qu'on trouve sur les mains font
ce que les yeux kreider
parce qu'il faut être fou pour se lancer
dans un tel projet peut parfois il nous
semble même difficile de croire que nous
avons accompli tout cela
[Musique]